Pope Francis has delivered his virtual
Easter Mass to over a billion worshipers
around the world it was the first Easter
Sunday Mass held that had no public
participation the Pope has been carrying
out virtual masses for weeks now in a
bid to urge worshipers not to leave
their homes skies Sally Lockwood has
this update now from the Vatican last
year there were 70,000 people gathered
where I'm standing now in Saint Peter's
Square and of course as this lockdown
continues here in Italy yet more surreal
themes as you see this deserted st.
Peter's Square the Pope has given a
private service inside st. Peter's
Basilica today which of course would
normally be packed as well just a
handful of people there for that private
service that was streamed around the
world and we've been waiting to see
whether he may make an appearance this
is a rather unpredictable Pope he's had
some rather spontaneous appearances in
the last few weeks as Italy and jaws
this crisis but we haven't yet had any
confirmation as to whether we may see
him today now we do have the benefit of
an empty st. Peter's Square to give you
a little tour of the Vatican here so the
top right hand second from right top
window there is where the Pope would
normally appear on a Sunday for an
audience with the Pope here to greet the
clout of the crowds that are normally
gathered here the worshippers and
tourists but on Easter Sunday he appears
at the lodger which is the balcony in
the center of the Basilica behind me now
of course he hasn't made an appearance
yet today but the gate beneath that
balcony was opened around an hour ago
and then closed again and there's also a
platform which has been erected in front
of the gate around half an hour ago a
covering was put there so we don't know
what that means we're speculating and
watching and waiting to see if Pope
Francis may make an appearance earlier
in March he walked through Rome's empty
streets without any prior warning to pay
a visit to a church here which contains
a rather famous crucifix to make some
prayers for the end of this pandemic and
then on
27th of March which was the worst day
for Italy so far in this crisis with the
greatest loss of life nearly a thousand
people dying in a 24-hour period he also
made an appearance here in st. Peter's
Square rather dramatic images of him
praying for an end to the pandemic in
the pouring rain so it could be that he
does make a surprise appearance today
this important date in the Christian
calendar but there's been no
confirmation yet so far
now of course Italy remains in lockdown
its into its fifth week in lockdown now
and that was extended on Friday night by
the prime minister Drew's epic content
or the third of May which is three weeks
today now many Italians here they've had
this deadline extended a few times now
they will be hoping that that isn't just
another date for a review that that will
in fact mean an end to this very strict
lockdown that's been in place now here
in Italy and if indeed the lockdown is
lifted on the 3rd of May that will mean
nearly eight weeks of national lockdown
huge effort and sacrifice by the Italian
people and of course it's important to
remember today as people here and around
the world watch Pope Francis and his
proceedings here online that we've been
reporting of course as staggering
figures of people losing their lives on
a daily basis for more than seven weeks
now and behind each and every one of
those figures our loved ones and
grieving families who will be dealing
with their grief and sadness today and
of course many other families who can't
be together this Easter because of this
lockdown so scenes that we're witnessing
here in st. Peter's Square may of course
provide some comfort